الطائر اصبح كلبا بقوه قانون ايلون ماسك
الملياردير الامريكي يقول انه غير شعار
منصه تويتر ولا تعرف بعد جديه ماسك من
مزحه الا ان البعض كشف انها دعايه من ماسك
لعمله دوك وين المشفره التي يتبناها
ماسك نشر تغريده مقتضبه على صفحته الرسميه
على تويتر قال فيها كما وعدت ارفق بها
صوره من تغريدات متبادله بينه وبين احد
المستخدمين الاخرين الذي طلب منه تغيير
شعار تويتر المعروف بالطائر الازرق الى
عمله دوكين
وسابقا سمح بدفع قيمه سيارات تسلا
الكهربائيه بهذه العملات الافتراضيه
اتبناها بعد ان قرر الابتعاد عن بيتكوين
وغرد عنها عده مرات من قبل
خطوه ماسك ادت الى صعود قيمه الى ما يصل
الى 10.2 سنت من حوالي 7.7 اي بنسبه تصل
الى 30% وتعد هذه العمله الثامنه اكثر
العملات المشفره قيمه حيث تبلغ قيمتها
السوقيه اكثر من 13 مليار دولار
خطوه ماسك تاتي بعد تغييرات كثيره احدثها
على منصه تويتر التي ظلت هادئه الى ان
سيطر عليها بلال البجدين العربيه